shooting yesterday at YouTube's
headquarters in California wounded three
people but left only the shooter dead
the killer was an Iranian refugee named
Nasim Ogden apparently Ogden believed
that YouTube's content policies that
somehow sabotage her efforts to become a
digital video star in raids she drove to
the company's headquarters and opened
fire that's what we know now let's pause
for a moment and pretend this is not the
8:00 p.m. show on Fox News let's pretend
it's somewhere else on the dial maybe
CNN or MSNBC are actually any other
cable channel or newspaper in America if
that were true by definition we'd have
to draw hard and fast conclusions from
this tragedy using a limited facts set
available we don't really know much at
this stage but sweeping dumb
generalizations are what the media do so
we would do that and of course we'd need
a very specific script in order to make
those generalizations so what we
conclude from what happened yesterday
well first off the shooter was a woman
she was female
so clearly America has a problem with
toxic femininity and we need to address
that crisis right away starting with
more University panel shaming an entire
gender somebody alert the HR department
to this and then there's the gun we'd
focus relentlessly on the gun because
nothing is more pivotal in a shooting
than the weapon that was used it's
always the guns fault always the shooter
in this case used a Smith & Wesson
9-millimeter handgun those guns need to
be banned tomorrow along with all other
assault pistols if you disagree with
that you're evil next the shooter was a
vegan and a supporter of PETA therefore
PETA is now a terrorist organization
anyone who supports PETA even those
supporters who disapprove of mass
shootings is a monster and his blood on
his hands let's hope that CNN hosts a
town hall meeting where YouTube
employees can scream at PETA spokesmen
they deserve to be screamed at they
caused the shooting oh wait media
outlets aren't reaching any of those
conclusions why not well because there's
no obvious way to use this shooting to
advance the objectives of the Democratic
Party so the media will stop talking
about it soon that's how corrupt they
are they're all so incredibly stupid
especially in the subject of firearms
the people yelling at you about guns and
television aren't sure what and the
bullet comes out of their kids their
children with all the ignorance and
moral certainty of fifth graders we
could show you a million examples of
that because they're everywhere but
here's the most amusing
we've seen recently it happened
yesterday this is MSNBC's resident
genius Nicole Wallace mistaking the
opening of a soda can for gunfire watch
Steve Schmidt I always go back to the
horror of 9/11 and the complete reliance
you know we are in our tribes we're in
our corners most of our lives I think we
just heard some gunshots we listened to
that for a second control room that's
not gunshots okay not gunshots no Nicole
Mike gunshots pretty funny but be
certain to listen very carefully as she
lectures you about the Second Amendment
because she knows a lot about it
Pete hagseth is Fox & Friends weekend
host he's a former member of the US
military a decorated one and he joins us
tonight so Pete it's a pretty simple
question we kind of know the script we
know these the way these things unfold
how they're analyzed in the press we
draw sweeping conclusions from a pretty
limited set of facts you're not hearing
that tonight you're not hearing the
other channel say toxic femininity is a
threat to America why is that well of
course you're not wrong bad guy Tucker
wrong bad guy female of Iranian descent
she's a fitness buff she's a vegan she's
a PETA member not an NRA member not a
trump supporter not a member of the NRA
and as a result doesn't fit the very
convenient narrative and as a result its
silenced Tucker I mean it is NBC CBS
negligent coverage ABC glancing blow NBC
said she's apparently in in animal
rights activist they're moving away from
this as quickly as they can with almost
imagine if it was an interim member that
did this you see apparently an IRA
member or is he actually an NRA member
in this case apparently an animal rights
activist but no I mean no judgment or
blood on the hands of a PETA member
always blood of the hands of an NRA
member because it would be absurd to me
to to define an entire population as
violent because they believe in animal
rights just like it's absurd to believe
an entire population of Second Amendment
supporters it believes in violence
because they support our rights so I'm a
little confused here so what you're
suggesting and my producer has said in
my ear he's watching the other channels
none of them are covering this right now
that the
of gun crimes really isn't an effort to
reduce the number of gun crimes it's an
effort to make a series of partisan
points it's an effort to impugn the
Second Amendment and those who support
it Tucker I mean ultimately it all
depends on the labels that apply
you know this identity politics are
one-sided if you a white Christian male
who voted for Donald Trump and believe
in the Second Amendment who owns an
ar-15 then you must be have a proclivity
to violence but you are a female of any
other shade who owns a handgun and
supports animals and you commit violence
nothing to see here turn the channel
Good Morning America as they did this
morning will not even cover this this
deal this this shooting and won't draw a
larger narrative as a result again
apparently an animal rights activist
this is what this is what the modern
media has turned into cheerleading for a
cause which is taking away our guns
which is exactly what we know they want
to do as opposed to reporting the news
and then moving on if it's not relevant
it doesn't sound like journalism machine
to me that it crosses a line when it
moves from attacking the president
personally they don't like Trump I get
it he doesn't like them by the way sure
but from that which you could sort of
understand it you know probably
shouldn't do it but I get it
- moving over to advocating for specific
policies that affect 320 million
Americans as if there's only one side of
the debate it moves from childish
annoyance to full-on propaganda of core
doesn't know I've heard I've heard
journalists on other networks say it is
our obligation to continue to talk talk
about the Parkland shooting because we
owe it to the American people to keep
the conversation alive if we don't talk
about it
the conversation doesn't continue and
policies don't change in Washington DC
if that doesn't sound like active
activism I don't know what is I mean
it's your job to report the news that is
relevant and the shooting a mass
shooting is of course relevant you cover
it and then you move on as necessary but
before deciding what to cover and dwell
on to try to do that's right but what's
so striking is I mean if you're gonna
pick a topic that the media would lobby
on maybe camera angles are lighting they
sort of make up I mean they're experts
on that stuff but is there any
America that knows less about firearms -
Cole Wallace mistook a soda opening for
the shots I opened my my my Diet
Mountain Dew which I happen to like and
no one around here jumped and thought it
was an ar-15 let alone a nine-millimeter
I mean I need Diet Mountain Dew cuz I'm
up at 6:00 in the morning like you used
to be it keeps us awake but I've never
mistaken nor do anyone I know would
mistake that his gunfire they know
nothing Tucker how many members of this
media are members of the NRA how many of
them have ever fired an ar-15 let alone
Mr M for which I carried let alone a 249
squad automatic weapon they don't know a
squad out of my weapon from a BB gun yet
they're gonna tell me what I what I can
or cannot carry of course it's political
activism to help their Democratic
buddies there in the tank it's not
convenient they're not gonna cover it
who put all the dumb people on TV I
always ask myself it's great to see you
you're not one of them and I appreciate
your coming on thank you thank you